hier nun also zugeschaltet die gründer
von anker kraut stefan und anne lembke
guten morgen erstmal an sie beide die
allererste frage ist eigentlich haben
sie vor vier jahren als sie da von der
jury standen mit so einem erfolg
gerechnet
als wir in der show war waren wir so
nervös da haben wir erst mal mit gar
nicht gerechnet muss ich sagen
und nein das hat man natürlich nicht und
das ist ja wie ein traum die ein märchen
was jetzt plötzlich passiert ist ja wir
sind auch wirklich total dankbar dass
wir dass wir so was tatsächlich erleben
dürfen also es ist wirklich wie ein
traum der in erfüllung gegangen ist und
es war so aufregend damals in der show
ich weiß es noch wie gestern und ja toll
dass er frank an uns geglaubt hat und
jetzt können wir das ganze gemeinsam zum
erfolg führen und verkauft haben wir
auch nicht wir haben ja nur eine
beteiligung mit dazu genommen
jetzt sind sie trotzdem gewürz
millionäre dadurch geworden was wollen
sie jetzt mit dem geld machen
ich habe mir eine wander app die
vollversion einer person sondern als
erstes besorgt das war mein herz gefühl
wir haben uns gestern in den dolomiten
verlaufen aber das war meine welt mit
zukunft uns ist total wichtig wir sind
ja auch eine familie wir haben zwei
kinder wie man gerade gesehen hat und es
ist total wichtig dass wir das risiko
was wir damals eingegangen sind als wir
unsere jobs an den haken gehangen haben
und alles auf eine karte gesetzt haben
und das war letztendlich der grund für
den für diesen schritt dass wir das
risiko für uns als familie und für
unsere kinder ein bisschen minimieren
und geld zur seite schaffen können damit
wir eine solide ausbildung bieten können
und ja wir wollen unter anderem aber
auch weiter natürlich auch selber in
ankara kraut investieren und zb eine
sehr sehr sehr große neue logistik
produktionshalle bauen
meine nächste frage gewesen wie soll es
jetzt mein anker kraut weitergehen wir
gerade selber gesagt haben nicht
verkauft sie sind natürlich noch im
unternehmen was sind die zukunftspläne
wir wollen paneuropäische expandieren
und das heißt also wir werden bestimmte
länder was wir jetzt noch nicht sagen
können aber bestimmte länder in europa
dann als neue märkte erschließen wir
werden
wir werden einen produktionsstandort
bauen sehr sehr sehr modern und schön
und ja wir machen einfach das was wir
auch die letzten paar jahre schon
gemacht haben die besten gewürze der
welt mit ganz viel liebe und wir freuen
uns auf die weiteren aufgaben auch mit
fand ihren der ja auch weiterhin noch an
bord ist und wir konnten unser
management zwei jungs die ich schon
lange bei uns arbeiten tina und alex die
sind jetzt auch mit im
gesellschafterkreis management buy out
heißt das sie sind also jetzt auch
mitinhaber der firma und das war uns
auch ganz wichtig